let's imagine we have a huge cloud of
hydrogen atoms floating in space Hugh
and I say huge cloud huge both in
distance and in mass if you were to
combine all of the hydrogen atoms it
would just be this really really massive
thing so you have this huge cloud well
we know that gravity would make the
atoms actually attracted to each other
instantly we normally don't think about
the gravity of atoms but it would slowly
affect these atoms and they'd slowly
draw close to each other it would slowly
condense they'd slowly they slowly move
towards the center of mass of all of the
atoms
they'd slowly move in and so if we fast
forward if we fast forward this cloud is
going to get denser and denser it's
going to get denser and denser and the
hydrogen atoms are going to start
bumping into each other and rubbing up
against each other and interacting with
each other and so it's going to get
denser and denser and denser and
remember was a huge mass of hydrogen
atoms so the temperature is going up the
temperature is going up and it'll
they'll keep condensing they'll just
keep condensing and condensing until
something really interesting happens so
let's imagine that they've gotten really
dense here in the center they've gotten
really dense here in the center and
there's a bunch of hydrogen atoms all
over it's really dense I could never
draw the actual number of atoms here
this is really give you an idea there's
a huge amount of inward pressure from
gravity from everything that wants to
get to that center of mass of our entire
cloud the temperature here the
temperature here is approaching 10
million Kelvin and at that point
something neat happens it to kind of
realize the neat thing that's happening
let's remember what a hydrogen atom
looks like a hydrogen and even more I'm
just going to focus on the hydrogen
nucleus so the hydrogen nucleus is a
proton if you want to think about a
hydrogen atom it also has an electron
orbiting around or floating around and
let's draw another hydrogen atom over
here and obviously this distance isn't
to scale this distance is also not to
scale atoms are actually the nucleus of
atoms are actually much much much much
smaller than the actual radius of an
atom and so is the electron but anyway
this just gives you an idea
so we know from the Coulomb forces from
electromagnetic forces that these two
positively charged nucleus is will not
want to get anywhere near each other but
we do know from ours from what we
learned about the four force is that if
they did get close enough to each other
that if they did get if somehow they're
under huge temperatures and huge
pressures you were able to get these two
protons close enough to each other then
all of a sudden the strong force will
overtake it's much stronger than the
Coulomb force and that these two
hydrogen's will actually these this
these nucleuses would actually fuse or
that nuclei well anyway they would
actually fuse together and so that is
what actually happens once this gets hot
and dense enough you now have enough
pressure enough temperature to overcome
the Coulomb force and bring these
protons close enough to each other for
fusion to occur for fusion fusion
ignition ignition and the reason why is
and I want to be very careful it's not
ignition it's not combustion in the
traditional sense it's not like you're
burning a carbon molecule with out in
the presence of oxygen it's not
combustion it's ignition and the reason
why it's called ignition is because when
two of these protons or two of the
nucleus is fuse the resulting the
resulting nucleus has a slightly smaller
mass and so in the first stage of this
you actually have you actually have two
protons two protons under enough
pressure obviously this would not happen
with just the Coulomb forces at with
enough pressure to get close enough and
then the strong interaction actually
actually keeps them together one of
these guys degrades in a neutron
degrades into a neutron and the
resulting mass of the combined protons
is lower than the mass of each of the
original by a little bit but that a
little bit of mass results in a lot of
energy plus plus energy and this energy
is why we call it ignition and so what
this energy does is it provides a little
bit of outward pressure so that this
thing doesn't keep keep collapsing so
once you get pressure enough the fusion
occurs and then that energy provides
outward pressure to
what is now a star what is now a star so
now we are at where we actually have the
ignition at the center we have and we
still have all of the other molecules
trying to get in providing the pressure
for this fusion ignition now what is the
hydrogen being fused into well on the
first step of the first step of the
reaction and I'm just kind of doing the
most basic type of fusion that exhibit
ours
the hydrogen gets fused into deuterium
deuterium of trouble spelling which is
another way of calling heavy hydrogen
this is still hydrogen because it has
one proton and one Neutron now it is not
helium yet it does not have two it does
not have two protons but then the
deuterium keeps fusing and then we
eventually end up with and then we end
up with helium and we can even see that
on the periodic table I lost my periodic
table well I'll show you in the next
video but we know hydrogen hydrogen
hydrogen in its atomic state has an
atomic number of one and it also has a
mass of one it only has one nucleon and
it's nucleus but it's being fused it
goes to hydrogen too which is deuterium
which is one Neutron one proton in its
nucleus two nucleons and then that
eventually gets fused and I'm not going
to the detail of the reaction into
helium and by definition helium has two
protons and two neutrons so it has or
we're talking about helium four in
particular that isotope of helium it has
an atomic mass of four and the whole
this process releases a ton of energy
because the atomic mass of the helium
that gets produced is slightly lower
than four of its of the atomic four
times the atomic mass of each of the
Constituent hydrogen's so all of this
energy all of this energy from the
fusion but it needs super high pressure
super high temperatures to happen keeps
keeps the star from collapsing and once
the star is in in this stage once it is
once it is using hydrogen it is fusing
hydrogen in its core where the pressure
and the temperatures of most to form
helium it is now in its main
sequence this is now a main sequence
star main main sequence star and that's
actually where the Sun is right now now
there's there's questions of well what
if what if there just wasn't enough mass
to get to this level over here and there
actually are things that never get to
that quite that threshold to fuse all
the way into helium there are a few
things that don't quite make the
threshold of stars that only fuse to
this level so they are generating some
of their eat or there are even smaller
objects that just get to the point
there's a huge temperature and pressure
but fusion is not actually occurring
inside of the core and something like
Jupiter would be an example and you can
go several several masses above Jupiter
where you get something like that so you
have to reach a certain threshold or the
mass where the pressure and the
temperature due to the heavy mass gets
so large that you start this fusion at
but the smaller you have above that
threshold this the slower the fusion
will occur but if you're supermassive
the fusion will occur really really fast
so that's a general idea of just how
stars get formed and why they don't
collapse on themselves and why they are
these kind of little balls of fusion
reactions existing in the universe and
the next few videos we'll talk about
what happens once that hydrogen fuel and
the cure in the core starts to run out